Nick is like in his villain monologue right now, [music] right?
He's doing his villain monologue and people are like, "Wait,
how do we beat him? How do we win right now?" No, the past like
eight years have been this getting set up. Not through Nick's
effort entirely, even not even majority. Like a ton of it just
through the things that happened. Nick is now the guy that like
dude, he won. He's already won. This is like the victory lap
you're witnessing.
But what I was really wanting to watch was the Asmin Gold reaction
to
Ben Shapiro's talking. >> Put those aside and align. >> This
This is what I want to watch. I want to give this a look. Okay.
I want to see Asmin Gold's reaction cuz I want to see the direction
Asmin Gold's going in. I want to see where his head's at with
regards to this GOP civil war cuz I feel like Asmin Gold would
have kind of been a little bit on Ben Shapiro's side earlier
in his life.
People think of him as a libertarian.
I don't think there's even one ounce of Asmin gold left in the
Benjamin, sorry, in the Ben Shapiro camp. Okay. I think he's
moved on entirely. I think he's going to try to bury Ben in this
video,
>> but I'm interested to see. Okay, >> and what he
was saying about Ben. >> Um, this is a video of him
showing himself playing Grand Theft Auto, right? A video game
where you people. And he's pretending that this character in
the video is Ben. Let's watch. >> This is so cringe.
Insanely cringe.
GOT the worst clip. Dude, you could tell everybody. You could
tell who everyone is based on the reaction to this clip, right?
If they just think this clip is like awesome just by itself.
I thought it was going to be cool cuz I thought they'd get the
whole thing or I thought they get the highlights, but they just
got like one early part where you can't see the person. If if
people don't know that and they act like they know everything,
I don't know. We'll see. We'll see. >> This one never used
to be a Twitch streamer. Remember that? How does he take that
many bullets? Shouldn't he die? [laughter] >> Oh, that's
funny, man. That makes me laugh and laugh.
That's a funny one.
What a chance encounter that was. I think I just saw Ben Shapiro.
>> And it goes on. I I feel like there's like 50 Nick Fentes
clips that you can show that are like a lot worse than that.
[laughter] >> Yes. Okay. Asmin Gold knows. Asmin Gold's
a knower.
>> Like him a guy in Grand Theft Auto. I mean I I I
>> mean in general I mean I Yeah, obviously like saying
his name it's definitely kind of weird but like I wouldn't have
used that clip. Okay, let me just say >> it goes on. I
mean, I I would hate for people to believe that that the Nick
Fuentes sort of my my problems with Nick Fuentes are about me
because they really are not. Uh they are about the fact that
that Nick Fuentes
is a truly horrifying person who believes truly horrifying things.
And again, there there is a reason why Charlie Kirk despised
him. There's a reason why
every mainstream political commentator has been highly critical
of him. It's the reason why these are these are not arguments.
is not a person who's making arguments. He is a he's a a troll.
And I say that advisedly. He literally says on his show that
he loves Adolf. Okay. So the So just the reason this has come
up in recent weeks is because Tucker, your guest last night,
decided to have him on last week and to I don't think it's a
problem bringing people on the show. I don't think it's a big
deal. Um, I I think you can criticize Tucker not pushing back
against people, but I think that he applies that pretty evenly.
I mean, he did the same thing. I would say that one thing that
would make Tucker seem less reliable as a
person who's interviewing is the way that he treated uh Ted Cruz.
>> Oh, this is not a good example. >> Vladimir. So
that is that is the example, but it's not a good example. I don't
like that Asigold's coming up with that off the top of his head.
>> Putin, which I mean obviously there's going to be a
difference there. I wonder why. But and and also Nick Fuentes,
right? Cuz he was very combative with Ted Cruz.
But why
>> completely gloss him in my opinion? And you can make
up your own opinion as to what you think Tucker was doing during
that interview, but I know what it looks like when Tucker Carlson
decides to be an aggressive interview or when he >> platforming
is a big deal. I mean, >> he said Putin. He said Ted Cruz,
the interview with Ted Cruz versus the interview with Putin or
the interview with Fuentes. That's what Asenville just said.
And but like wouldn't you say platforming Putin would be more
and also it doesn't really if if if like let's say theoretically
like somebody you think is a right gains a tremendous amount
of prominence inside of a political space do you think that it's
a good idea to not to like how long do you think you should pretend
like they don't exist
until you acknowledge that?
Do you see the problem there? Right?
like not platforming people is a
there's a time limit on that and eventually it ends. That's it.
You don't need to platform them. But what I'm saying I think
Ben is trying to argue asenold had this off the bat. So I don't
know where this is coming from. Big Ben is trying to argue that
while platforming is okay, platforming without, you know, bringing
up some of his views, if this guy just wants to come on and do
his standup comedy routine, it's like if had a good standup comedy
routine, should people have still criticized him, should they
still let him or should they have just brought him on comedy
shows and let him do his routine and become really popular with
people, right? is is the argument Ben is trying to make >> is
that if you tr if you tell people that you can't platform certain
individuals and those individuals continue to grow and consolidate
power
eventually there's a point where that that opinion becomes mainstream
and that's happened many times in history. It's not like this
is the first time this has happened. There have been many times
where people that have had extreme opinions have, you know, been
marginalized or removed and then over time they get bigger and
bigger and bigger until they have enough to lead some form of
political resistance.
So I think that just not platforming a person is simply not a
solution to avoiding a conversation about an idea you disagree
with.
it it is
he's not wrong. No, he is. He just said not platforming somebody
is not a solution to avoiding a conversation like a political
conversation. It is literally the solution. I just won't talk
to them. That's literally the solution. Now, making it not effective,
that's different. Maybe he just misspoke cuz he was talking about
the idea becoming prominent. So, if you want to prevent an idea
from becoming prominent, then not engaging with it is is probably
not always the best solution. Unfortunately for Ben, even if
he engages with it at this point, he will only help. He will
only help Nick Fuentes, right?
I talked about this on Twitter earlier today. Ben has set up
he's he's set up in a cultural position similar to Hillary Clinton
in 2016. Doesn't matter how competent Ben is. It doesn't matter
how correct Ben is. The cultural tides against him and you can't
fight the tide. People will say anything Fuentes says is funny.
Anything Fentes says against you is is funny and cool. Right?
You're just going to lose. Even if you're correct on every the
best case scenario for Ben Shapiro debating Nick Fuentes directly
would be he is correct on literally everything he says he is
never wrong he totally owns Nick logically in every way
that's a draw that the best they could do is Nick just doesn't
grow more if Bened up one iota
and that gets clipped it's over like that does so much harm to
his reputation it does so much to booster or sorry bolster Nick
Fuentes's reputation
right So you just you just don't know what to do. How would you
have stopped Nick before he got big? Literally kill him. No,
deplatform him in the way they did. Uh also just in general,
the way you stop Nick is you don't run on ideas you don't believe
in. So you don't run on populism. You don't run on like jingoistic
populism that that others like a minority, right? Because then
that same jinguistic like populism that demagoguery can be turned
on to you and the minority group you belong to.
Like it's it's over when you start supporting ideas that will
one day be used as the knife that cuts your throat.
That's Ben's problem, right? Is he outwardly supported people
who used ideas and weaponized ideas that could be used against
him. He can't send Matt Walsh. Matt Walsh is a loser. Matt Walsh
agrees with Nick. The issue with Matt Walsh is Matt Walsh either
has to lie or he has to go, "Yeah, you're right. Yeah, you're
right. Yeah, we agree there. Yeah, we agree there." There's no
winning with Matt Walsh either. The issue is, okay, the issue
is always going to be that the Gropers are just more of what
MAGA is than anyone else who's going right now. That's the problem.
The base aligns with them way more than anybody else. There's
no amount of like, oh, Nick Fuentes is an anti-semite. Nick Fuentes
is an anti-semite that's going to make it okay that Ben Shapiro
can't disavow the operations in Gaza, Israel's actions broadly,
October, sorry, the the overreach since October 7th, Netanyahu
himself or oh, what's the other one? Apac funding in America.
Like, if if Ben's not willing to disavow any of those things
or criticize any of those things, but he wants to use anti-semitism
as a blade against you, nobody will take him seriously. That's
the cultural window is past that.
What is 50 Cent doing right now? Oh, no idea
Read above. Oh,
you hire another black rapper to get him to abandon his movement
again and waste. Oh,
what's 50 Cent doing? Oh, I see. I don't think there's another
guy like Kanye. I'm trying to think.
Yeah, I think the the way you beat Fuentes right now, like the
only tactical decision for Ben Shapiro is to like flee. He's
got to retreat, right? He's got to sit back. You've got to wait
for Fuentes to make mistakes. I think Fuentes has grown so fast
he doesn't have a solidified coalition. He doesn't have anything
really solidified.
Right now is like the crescendo of that movement. You cannot
fight him now. Now is the chance where like there's a if you
lose, if you go down now that could start solidifying public
opinion against you. What you hope is that they make mistakes
that some attack lands that some new like opposition like research
comes out that you could use and weaponize against him. Right
now Ben has no shot. He would just get run the [__]
over. Yeah. Um Milo does no more. Milo doesn't know enough. I
don't I don't think the Ali Akbar stuff could be used against
him, right? I think with the with the Ali Akbar stuff, the best
you could do is hope that somebody debates Fuentes and then they
bring it up and Fuentes like really fumbles his answer in some
way. But maybe that's the thing they could do.
I think the the issue is Fuentes is giving, you know, voice to
a certain anger in the voter base right now that people aren't
really aligned with. Sorry. um that a lot of politicians aren't
really aligned with. Special interests aren't aligned with and
that's that's the issue is MAGA has run as a party like giving
sort of using this as their bullhorn and now Fuentes is saying
hey you used all of my issues like all of the things I'm angry
about that I've been talking about for a long time used them
all to run and now I'm saying actually govern that way
and all they're doing is watching all the people who refuse to
govern the way they ran and calling them out. Right? That's all
they're doing.
I just don't think so. Got imprisoned. Yeah, they put him in
jail. They put Lynon in jail, too.
>> Ask difficult questions of people. Tucker is imminently
capable of doing that. He did it to Ted Cruz quite
>> He decided for >> tons of spam as cold chat. Uh,
America first, Wang half, Wang half, Wang half. >> Any
number of reasons. And I I I try not to attribute motivations
to people that he was going to treat Fuentes with kid gloves.
that that he was going to not ask him about any of the things
that I've just mentioned, literally any of them. Uh, and to essentially
normalize Fuentes, act as a sort of gateway drug or as a and
what what I've called Tucker as an ideological launderer of bad
ideas over the last couple of years. And and this is not coming
from a place of animist for Tucker on a personal level. I I've
known Tucker for a very long time. Tucker and whenever we're
in personal situations, we get along great. I think I I saw that
Tucker talked about how we were at Charlie's memorial in the
vice president's box together. And he's correct. I mean, we saw
each other, we said hello, we talked, it was very friendly and
all of that. And it's also true that a couple of days after Charlie's
murder, he reached out and he called me and he said, "Listen,
I know that we're at odds and you know, we've been at odds for
a number of reasons, mainly political. I mean, again, on a personal
level, I'd go fishing with Tucker anytime. The the the real question
is for me, I got into this business because I care about the
ideas and I care about the ideals." And >> so when you
are determining what is conservatism, what should the future
of America look like? And where do you draw the lines? Those
are the questions that I need to answer in my job. For me, my
business is really not >> I think that right now somebody
like Ben Shapiro is going to have a really hard time winning
over the moral authority when he's align >> Netanyahu Israel.
Netanyahu Israel himself so strongly with Israel.
I think this is it. It's such a massive issue for a lot of people
that I don't think that people will look past it until he moves
past it, which I don't think that he necessarily will. But I
think that that's really
that that's the perspective that a lot of people have. Like I
I think that somebody asked him like, you know, which do you
like more like America? Is >> Oh, that's the other thing
about him debating Fentes is Fentes is just going to hammer him
to disavow Netanyahu. He's going to bring up dead kids. Netanyahu,
dead kids. Apac and Ben will Ben will stand on all of those issues.
He absolutely will. >> Real and he didn't want to answer
the >> Won't look good for him. >> Do you really
want to listen to somebody who's a political commentator who
doesn't know
Do you want to listen to somebody for advice on America politics
that doesn't know if their favorite country is America?
I don't I mean just categorically
about friendship. I have lots of friends, people who I love with
whom I disagree in politics and don't believe they should be
leaders in the conservative movement, for example. And and that
to me is is the real question. Any case, Tucker reached out.
He he said, you know, >> I'm so psyched that um I'm so
psyched that Asmin Gold now fully kind of aligning behind the
America First movement. I'm so glad that Asmin Gold and you know,
Dan Alman, H3, the Destiny Sphere, they all teamed up to Plan.
That was definitely the political influencer that had to go down,
guys. That was the real threat to America, wasn't it? That was
the real threat to worldwide.
>> We [laughter] had a bunch of disagreements and you know
what? If we could put those aside and align toward the DSA in
particular is what he mentioned. And I said, you know, Tucker,
you're totally right. Let's do that. That would be great. >> In
fact, the TSA >> the DSA. DSA. The Democratic Socialist.
>> Why the TSA? How did that bring you >> The Democratic
Socialist America. And the reason that I know >> and Yes.
And and the reason that I'm >> TSA only divides people
>> is because Yes. The reason I'm taking out my phone is
because it's I I don't just, you know, I like to evidence what
I'm saying with, you know, actual evidence. So, I texted him.
>> Somebody says, "Uh, I I think you're wrong and 5 minutes
with Nucks. Talk to you will also change your mind because Israel
has been portrayed more wrongfully than they [laughter] >> dude.
Yes, please. As Gold Nux collab as soon as possible, please.
>> They deserve."
I still don't even if Israel is the greatest country in the world,
I still don't want to hear somebody telling me that and then
telling me what I should think about American politics. Kosher
Conservatives. I didn't know people are calling Jesus. I didn't
know this people were calling this group the kosher
Oh, no one no one in Asmigle's chat is buying that at all. By
the way,
>> that's not the point. The point is that I want somebody
who is direct
still loves America over any other country though. No, he doesn't.
He's not even American. He's Canadian Israeli.
He doesn't even live in America. You idiot.
Invested
and only invested in America to be talking about and giving me
opinions about American politics. I don't like Israel like the
way that their government does things and the their military
seems pretty bad, right? I'm not I I don't attribute any of this
guilt to the Israeli people. I don't have any animist or negativity
towards them. I don't hate
uh No, you should have animist for the Israeli people who vote
for this stuff, but you just shouldn't hate ethnically.
They do ultimately vote for this. This is the direction they
want to go in. This is what they vote for. Don't don't just say
it doesn't matter. It does matter. People have every right to
be at Americans when they vote for Donald Trump. And listen,
you could just say support for that, right? You you can delineate
between the types of voters, but people worldwide have every
right to be annoyed that Americans vote for Donald Trump. >> Like
I just think that it seems like a lot of bad stuff. But I'm not
really a big expert in this either, but I think that it's very
clear to see that the writings on the wall with the young people's
support of Israel.
It's very obvious to see that writing is on the wall. And if
you don't approach that writing in a way that's authentic and
reasonable and you meet voters where they are, well then they're
going to find somebody else that will. So that's the main issue.
Max is from Israel. Well, I again I I don't have any problem
[laughter] with Israel like in terms of
you literally have an Israel first amongst you right now. >> People
that are from it or anything like that like that.
>> No, he's not. No, he's not. Where is he from then, guys?
Nux is not from Israel. He's from Canada. Yes, he lives in Israel.
He is from Canada. >> Here's my actual opinion, right?
This is a Middle Eastern conflict,
thousands of miles away from me. >> Do these guys not know
that he's not living in Israel or that he is living in Israel?
I don't want to have to think about Israel whenever I'm talking
about
on a very fundamental level.
Like, I don't even want this to be part of the conversation.
the same as like talking about Indonesia isn't part of the conversation
or talking about Zimbabwe isn't part of the conversation. It
should not even be in the vocabulary.
>> And the and the text exchange was was very nice. I mean,
here here's what the actual text exchange went like after the
call. So, I texted him and I said, "Thanks so much for calling.
It means the world. It truly does. Should we do a show together
talking about the DSA >> Wait, wait, wait. What? Why is
Ben doing I didn't make this point yesterday. Ben's doing the
Candace me. suddenly just leaking texts out of nowhere. >> A
democratic socialist of America threat and orienting in the same
direction. Happy to do whatever it takes to bring everyone back
together for the fight that matters. And Tucker then wrote back,
"Thanks, man. I appreciate it. I'm going to spend the next week
or two thinking about how to be most effective. The country is
clearly on the brink." >> I reached out repeatedly after
that. Nothing happened. Um and again, I I thought it was a good
idea at the time. I I I I think I felt differently after I saw
what he did with with Nick Fuentes and after he proceeded in
my opinion to spend the subsequent weeks. These people will never
succeed if you purity test.
You you will never s It's the same as the leftwing is purity
testing itself to death. Uh like recently they've been dude I
I won't purity test at all. This is so funny, right? This is
unironically. I did not see this video before I posted the tweet,
but now I'm just becoming more and more confident that like literally
the problem is calling somebody anti-semitic. That's so much
worse than being anti-semitic. Calling someone anti-semitic,
that's disgusting. That's basically trying to cancel somebody.
Being anti-Semitic, listen, you shouldn't purity test beliefs,
okay? Purity testing is like the way you lose. actually been
able to consolidate around a couple of electors and you know
I think also their collective dislike of Trump but I don't think
there's any real consolidation or any real agreement among them.
Their only real agreement is that they don't like Donald Trump
and they want people that are oppositional to him >> doing
literally nothing to fight the
>> I say this with sadness because Tucker used to be I
think a a deeply important part of the conservative push to win.
I think that if Ben if if if Ben really wants to
overrule Nick Fentes's influence over I think a lot of young
people especially I think that he should engage with what Nick
is saying directly and engage Nick
Asminold thinks Asminold I can't tell if he doesn't understand
people are not Charlie Kirkp nobody's actually Charlie Kirkp
Kirk wasn't Charlie Kirkp nobody believes debate changes minds.
They all just want the clips dunking on the other side. That's
all Ben Shapiro would be showing up for. And the culture is against
him. He's like totally You already explained why he's totally
he can't show up and do this. His ideas won't work. Nick correctly.
I think that the, you know, talking about it and then saying
this is a person who does this.
I I think that really and this is something that people might
not want to hear, but I think there's a lot of people out there
now that do support him. They do. And it might I I'm not a fan.
I don't like
But the problem is that if there's a lot of people out there
that feel that way, you can't just tell them that's bad. You
can't have this opinion. And then they're all just going to change
their mind.
That's it's not going to work. You You can't play on the optics
of an argument and then expect, "Bro, my 70-year-old dad is watching
Nick Fuentes now." Yeah, I know. As I'm trying to manifest the
best content ever. Don't say no. JTock the content.
Uh, no. Ben Shapiro is too smart to do this. Ben Shapiro just
has to know. Listen, Ben made a fortune. Ben made hundreds of
millions of dollars, okay, off of doing this [__]
He just needs to take his ships off the table and go home. There
is no winning. There's only hurting. The only thing Ben can do
is hurt things. Okay? The only thing Ben can do is hurt America.
He should go. He should walk off. He should ride off into the
sunset. Okay? There's just no winning for him now. Tries to debate
Fuentes, he'll lose. He tries to just comment from the sidelines,
he'll lose. He can only do harm. To bully people into submission.
That's what woke people did for years, and it just didn't
Go. Would you say go to Israel? Well, if that's where he wants
to go, I don't know. Maybe he likes Argentina.
And and this is me saying this in his best interest. The number
of times that Tucker Carlson has mentioned >> See, that's
that's the problem right there, isn't it? That's the problem
right there. If he thinks that's in Ben Shapiro's best interest,
he's a
Zoran Mani since October 5th on his show is once and it was in
the context of Marjgerie Taylor Green and Tucker Carlson talking
about the appeal of Zoran Mandani just by way of contrast, not
because I'm a perfect. >> What did he say? He said it would
be in Ben Shapiro's best interest to debate Nick Fuentes. He's
like, I said all that. I'm just talking about Ben Shapiro's in
best Ben Shapiro's best interest. Would not be representative
here, but because >> it's not true. He mentioned him a
second time when he was talking to Charlie Kirk. But yes, talked
about Zor Manzani a lot. A lot of us have. Since October 5th,
I did 17 separate shows on Zoramani, including four in the last
week before the election. Okay. Because when you're orienting
against the left, you really should orient against the >> On
a show. Was that was that not on a show? I thought there was
>> a lot in there. >> I think that it's very hard.
Like one of the big issues is that uh he won't debate Nick the
fool. Yeah, Ben.
>> Uh if not Ben, then who challenges him? I don't know
that you could challenge him right now. You sorry. I just don't
think there's somebody equipped. I'm trying to think of like
who's equipped to challenge him. I don't on on the right wing.
The issue is like this is all baked in like the people are
You guys, I I can't remember watching Watchmen. Okay, I know
I've watched it. I know what the end is. Do you know the end?
Nick is like in his villain monologue right now,
right? He's doing his villain monologue and people are like,
"Wait, how do we beat him? How do we win right now?" No. The
past like 8 years have been this getting set up. Not through
Nick's effort entirely, even not even majority, like a ton of
it just through the things that happened. Nick is now the guy
that like dude, he won. He's already won. This is like the victory
lap you're witnessing, right? In terms of the Republican party.
Now, I'm sure there's something he could say that would be detestable
enough that he could get cancelled like for real, right?
But it's it's like the idea is Trump has run for three three
times now he's run on America first. I'm going to bring back
jobs. I care most about you. No more foreign wars. We won't be
sending money to a bunch of other countries to waste. We're going
to put Americans first.
Nick has the more the more accurate talking points for that belief
for the people who were captured by that belief who were captured
by Trump right who's Dr. Man who is Dr. Manhattan. I don't [__]
know, man. In this situ I don't know. But
in any case, it's like he's just walked into something where
he has a way better claim to this movement than anybody else.
And there is no one else who can uh challenge this guy.
Uh no, you guys, you guys actually I think Destiny might do worse
than Ben would. Destiny swept for the same genocide. No.
Like like and he's got way more scandal. I don't know what element
Destiny even attacks Nick on at this point. That was a joke.
Well, you guys are saying it. I I don't know. Destiny already
lost to him. In the same way, by the way, in the same way Nick
was just telling a story. Destiny had no way to push back against
the story without like precisely knowing what he's talking about.
And even if he precisely knew,
it's just the story. The story interlocks. It's it's like very
difficult to disassemble, right? when he's talking about how
Israel like uh controls geopolitics like especially Middle Eastern
I don't know Middle
>> and said in that last week oh maybe I I don't know I
thought say 8 months or something like that I have no idea but
um let me actually I'll just keep going I'll talk about later
>> I I think just to be clear so the the breakdown from
the like day after Charlie was him interviewing Fuentes like
was that the next thing that happened that >> led to the
blowup >> I mean Yes. I mean, I had not se I had not spoken
a word. I
>> No, Dean Withers is gay. Dean Withers sucks. Dean Withers
can't do it. It's not a lefty, by the way. It's not a lefty that
he's winning against. I'm not thinking he wins against lefties.
He wins against everyone else. My only thought on Nick Fentes
is that he wins over the Republicans.
Any Republican politician Fuentes wins over.
>> Wasn't that he attacked you like you had >> I
don't care about the sport.
I think a lot of young people they they consolidate around figures
like or Stalin. Like there's a lot of also leftists that love
Stalin too. And I think that the reason why they consolidate
around people like that is because those people are men of extreme
brutal action and people that changed their country
for I'd say probably for worse, but they changed their country.
And Castro, yeah, Fidel Castro is another one. Shay Vera. Yeah,
these are violent psychotic
like psychopath.
But also I think that Cheva, Fidel Castro, Stalin, all of these
people were very intelligent. Like they had high IQ. They were
not like uh you know some [__] 80 IQ idiot that doesn't
know how to do math. Like these people were highly intelligent.
It's just they were also very bad. So, and this is another big
issue that a lot of people have have trouble realizing is that
a lot of the very evil and very bad people
are not stupid.
They are not stupid at all. They are incredibly intelligent.
They are extremely intelligent. And if you if you if you don't
take that seriously, they will beat you, right? They will beat
you because you didn't take you didn't take them seriously. But
the reason why I think that people flock to leaders like that
is that they see leaders like that and they see a world.
I know he's like doing the Fentes thing here. What belief of
Fentes does he think is like uh evil there? Like what is what
is the the bad thing there without any sort of real path to improvement
that is sufficient to them? They don't feel like anything is
like it's not good enough basically. And because it's not good
enough, what they end up doing is they end up going to extremes.
They go to extremes like Stalin or like or like Chay or Fidel
Castro. And I think that that's really what why it's happening.
And so extreme
>> I've got that time you change.
>> And I think that both of those things are necessary.
>> Violence and nationalism.
And I think that really if you look at a lot of these different
uh people that extremists that are political uh view highly,
they are both they are all both of those two things. >> Was
that me? And I don't think >> was Lenin violent.
Oh, is it one of those one of those Marxist guys who led Russia?
I don't know any of that history, by the way, so forgive me for
not knowing. I thought one of those guys was explicitly trying
to be as as nonviolent as possible the whole time.
Is that am I crazy that now cuz there was so much blood in that
in like the bullshik revolution now I feel like that can't possibly
be true but
what the [__]
>> what did I just get sound kick it in
>> I literally don't know oh some tweet no
>> we good chat
>> the [__]
oh hold on.
Wait, where where is that coming from? [__] OH, I
raided somebody on kick yesterday. Oh, that was that was Corrontos
and Slicker, wasn't it? That's what that was. >> Who cares
about people attacking him? I mean, again, we're we're professionals.
We're in a business where people come. >> No, that was
um I raided out of my own channel into
Malik who raided into Gontos yesterday. >> Comment on on
what we say publicly. the, you know, again, this is why, you
know, I think you and I differ on our angle with regard to, for
example, Candace Owens. I think that what Candace Owens is doing
right now is evil. >> It is evil what she is doing right
now. >> Okay. And I say that again, >> but what what
>> like I I didn't know pine on whether it's evil or not,
but my my position is it's really none of my business. And >> why
is it But I have a question. Why is it none of your business?
>> Because she's not accountable to her. That's the reason.
And I think that collectively society has grown fatigued with
people in positions that are morally achieved
being the arbiters of what can and cannot be said. I think this
is a general sentiment. Morally
>> Candace Owens. I think that what Candace Owens is doing
right now is evil. It is evil what she is doing right now. >> Okay.
And I say that again. But what
>> I I didn't know pine on whether it's evil or not. But
my my position is it's really none of my business. And >> why
is it? But I have a question. Why is it none of your business?
>> Because she's not accountable to her. >> He's
not accountable to Candace.
Oh, Candace isn't accountable to Megan.
>> that's the reason. And I think that collectively society
has grown fatigued.
>> Okay. Asold can't possibly think that you he obviously
critiques people who aren't accountable to him.
It's about whether or not you should critique somebody doing
a moral wrong or not. Ben is arguing it's a moral wrong, right?
Should should other people critique that? Well, it depends. But
it's just
with people in positions that are morally achieved
being the arbiters of what can and cannot be said.
>> I don't know what this means. I think this is a general
sentiment. I think this sentiment extends to the support of Zoran
Mandami. I think it extends to the support of Nick Fuentes. I
think it extends to the support of Donald Trump. I think that
it extends to the support of someone like >> I think he's
generally saying that he doesn't want Ben Shapiro dictating to
him and probably because Ben Shapiro again like we've been saying
like everyone's been saying Ben Shapiro fully supports fullthuredly
supports what's happening in Gaza, right? fullthroedly supports
Netanyahu, fullthroatly supports all
anything to do with Israel, right? He is just always in full
support of it. And so morally, I don't want Ben Shapiro condescending
to anybody because he objectively licks the balls of a war criminal.
So off Ben, like Jay Jones,
people are past being morally policed. And I think this is something
that's happening with extreme left-wing and also extreme right-wing
people.
It's very evident. I mean, you you you comment on these things
for >> so that so I guess Asminold would have to admit
that he understands that he can't do anything about Hassan, right?
Cuz that's the extreme left to him. He must see Fentes and Hassan
as the same thing. No, is like counterpoints to each other. Is
that who has to stop Nick Fuentes is just Hassan? Son has to
show up and not be fat, be tall, be like all the things Fuentes
isn't, and then he just wins. Can he win entirely on aura? >> I'm
not mother of the internet. >> No, but but if this were
on the left and somebody were accusing Charlie Kirk of of his
wife having murdered him, I assume that you would >> It's
ridiculous. And I mean, let's be honest, it is >> talking
about it. >> Is that what Candace is accusing Erica
>> Of murdering her own husband. >> She She's accusing
TPUSA insiders and other members of the right-wing, including
Seth Dylan, of being involved.
Realistically, guys, just to be clear, nobody on the left can
debate Nick Fuentes out of the place he is in right-wing culture,
right? No debate he has with any leftwinger will move him. It
has to be somebody on the right. Obviously, somebody on the left
can argue all of the ways he's morally reprehensible, but it
won't matter. They've been arguing all of the ways Trump's morally
reprehensible. JD Vance is morally reprehensible. Steve Bannon's
morally reprehensible, Steven Miller's morally reprehensible.
They've been arguing this for years now, and it's done nothing.
So it doesn't matter if a left winger actually talks to him.
Doesn't matter at all >> in the murder of Charlie Kirk.
Yes. >> Okay. Like I said, I I don't take >> that
sounds It does. It sounds >> in that content, which is
an honest statement. I I don't have time. >> I have to
back it up cuz I was talking over the last >> thing that's
happening with extreme leftwing and also extreme rightwing >> My
bad. I was talking over them. I'm listening now.
>> I mean, you comment on these things for a little. >> I'm
not mother of the internet. No, but but if this were on the left
and somebody were accusing Charlie Kirk of of his wife having
murdered him, I assume that you would be >> That's ridiculous.
And I mean, let's be honest, it is >> talking about it.
>> Is that what Candace is accusing Erica
>> Of murdering her own husband. >> She She's accusing
TPUSA insiders and other members of the right-wing, including
Seth Dylan, of being involved in the murder of Charlie Kirk.
Yes. >> Okay. Like I said, I I don't take >> That
sounds
>> okay. It sounds [__] [__]
>> in that content, which is an honest statement. I I don't
have time to watch. >> I believe
>> is that when I think it's important, listen,
friendship, not Trump, >> we basically do do a weekly Candace
update, Grandy. We basically do. Candace saying all the time.
We watched Candace last night. Uh, also Candace will say she
didn't say any of these things. She didn't imply these things.
Um, I'm guessing she was asking questions that would lead one
to think that's what she thought, but that she has plausible
deniability on that nobody really believes. So why would we do
this whole dance, Candace? I have no [__] idea.
We don't even know, which I understand. But even with Tucker,
friendship should not trump our manifest requirement to speak
out when people do and say things that are both detrimental to
conservatism and morally wrong. >> Okay. So I I I don't
>> I think this is true. And this is true. There are people
like that. I you know like with with streaming there are people
that I criticize very regularly that are other streamers that
I'm friendly with. This is normal because there's a professional
and a personal barrier there. At least for me there is totally
disagree but I think the way of handling that at least for me
is much >> I think that really it's not about being professional
versus personal with her. I think that what Megan Kelly is saying
is that why are you dividing the this movement and purity testing
this movement when we're already on the back foot with a lot
of these issues? For example, like the economy, people are very
disappointed about the Epstein list. People are unhappy about
the fixation around Israel and around the Middle East in general.
And so really, it's not about being friends with this person.
It's about consolidating power and looking at a greater evil.
You know, there's like the old saying, me against my brother
or me and my brother against my cousin and me and my brother
and my cousin against the world. I think that that's really what
Megan Kelly is advocating for. Not necessarily
agreeing with Candace Owens and it's not something that's a personal
or a professional guideline.
>> Like I I don't even know why Ben would say that. That's
clearly not what's being that that that's not the conversation.
I I thought saw things go south between you and Tucker, at least
from my vantage point, when you disagreed on Israel. That was
obvious. And he he was, "Well, let me just make my point." And
so he was saying things that were critical of Israel and our
policy towards Israel. And then you did one show where you >> did
what I thought you should have done if you disagreed with him,
which clearly you did, which is say what you believe and what
you think is factual and like educate your audience on what you
think are the real facts and give them the evidence for it. But
you named him >> and it felt like an attack and that to
me was the beginning of the end where he was like now it's on
because he felt personally attacked by as opposed to just challenging
his idea. I think you named him and you you kind of diminished
him and you know he's an 800 lb gorilla and if you mess with
a gorilla he's going to fight and to me that's where it started
to go south and cuz I >> Yeah, it's straight up it is literally
the exact thing Trump ran on. Hey, the government tells you they're
on your side, but they're lying to you. I'm on your side. Look
at some of the stuff I've said before. Look at the stuff I'm
saying now. I'm on your side. And guess what? I'm not going to
be concerned about being a little racist or a little or a little
anti-semitic because I'm on your side. The important thing is
the message is the direction we're going. I am even more angry
about the things you're angry about than you are. That's the
energy that Trump won on. And it's it is the same thing. Yes.
And the people are doing the never Trump thing. They're they're
just trying to morally signal. And guess what? You can't morally
signal about how wrong these people are when you've been leaning
into those exact problems that they're a little racist, that
they're a little they're like bigoted, that they don't really
know how to evaluate media, right? You've been leaning into all
of these things to campaign, to get their
and now somebody else comes along and they're a little more racist.
They're a little more they're a little more bigoted in any way
that than you are, right? And they're assuming control. Oh, well,
who who could have possibly seen that coming? The exact thing
I selected my voters for is now being used against me. Oh, no.
>> Remember that day being like, "Oh,
I don't want to see this." >> But here's the thing. I I
would urge everybody to go back and listen to the show you're
referring to where I criticized Tucker's ideas, not Tucker as
a person. Tucker then responded by claiming that I do not love
America. That is a direct quote. That I do not love America because
I was spending too much time covering the October 7th attacks.
And then proceeded in January
It's problem. I don't know why Ben Shapiro can't address the
elephant in the room where when you're asked whether you like
America or Israel more, you don't answer the question. You don't
want to answer the question. This is going to make any American
suspicious of you. Any patriotic nationalistic American will
be suspicious of that.
I am suspicious of that.
>> It's just it's a red It's a red flag every time. And
right, they trained this entire base of people. They trained
everybody on Twitter who's a right-winger to go, "Oh, someone's
accusing you of being racist. They're trying to cancel you. They're
a leftist woke school and you couldn't possibly be racist." It
doesn't matter what the person was saying. The fact that they
were called racist is the number one indicator that they're in
the right. And now it's going to be exactly that way for anti-semite.
Okay? You call somebody an anti-semite and every right-winger
is going to go, "Oh, that person's in the right now." It will
how anti-semitic they're being will not even be questioned, will
not be talked about. Nobody will give a
that to be extremely problematic. I'm not speaking for other
people. I'm speaking for myself.
I don't like that.
I don't want anybody who doesn't think America is the greatest
country in the world with no reservations to be giving me advice
on American politics. I I don't know why. Why is this so hard?
That's a great question. Why is it so hard >> to then say
that I wanted his children to die in a foreign war? >> What
the >> Okay, so those are different rhetorical. >> Well,
well, yeah, but the thing is that Tucker is following a logical
chain of actions where if you are advocating for America defending
Israel
like is I mean it's a simple question. Would would Ben Shapiro
want you know if Israel was attacked would he ever want American
troops to go over to Israel? And if the answer to that is yes,
then I think Tucker's accusation is correct. Theoretically, hypothetically,
>> I suppose that is correct. Yeah. >> No, I'm sorry.
It's not. An attack on motivation is a very different
>> Ben kind of gets to opt out of that question, though,
because the US can park an aircraft carrier there and they don't
need to put boots on the ground. They can just knock out any
threat to Israel by parking an aircraft carrier there. That's
the power of the United >> Something from an attack on
an idea. His point was that you were sounding like a neocon and
he's upset with anybody who wants us to get too involved in Israel's
conflict because he feels it endangers American children. >> It
is it is a that okay the idea that number one the idea that I
want the United States to be directly involved in Israel's con
>> uh you full of hell you think that um you think Asoldold's
taking Tucker's side because he likes Tucker Carlson. He's taking
Tucker's side cuz Tucker is taking Nick's side. Okay.
Uh, if you asked Aspenold about that Russian grocery trip, Asminold
would, I'm positive, just go, "Yeah, that's weird. Yeah, that's
not America first at all."
>> No, I know that.
>> I've been urging Israel to get off of American aid for
literally as long as I have been active in politics. Where
>> his point was, >> but no, no, but that but my
point is that that's not his point. And again, none of this also
>> that's way different. Hold on. That is way different
than saying America should stop funding Israel. Right?
Those are different things. I have been encouraging Israel to
get off American aid is different than I have encouraged Americans
and American politicians to vote vote against people supporting
Israel. That's a way different thing. >> Well, we no we
disagree on >> so well this is and and this is it's a
it's an inversion of the way that Americans see this. So you're
seeing this as Israel getting away from America's aid whereas
I think a lot of >> you know you're not in a good position
when Asmin Gold can follow all of the contradictions you're laying
out for us Ben that's the issue here right to maintain to for
Ben to maintain his own interest he has to be insanely
um in terms of the MAGA views on the world he has to be insanely
hypocritical and anybody there's it's so obvious the the hypocrisy
is so glaring that even Asold can point it out Now,
Americans such as myself see it as us getting away from aiding
Israel.
And so, there's even an inversion of the way that the problem
is even perceived. And I'm speaking generally from my own perspective,
but that's the way that I see it.
>> The interpretation of what Tucker has been doing for
the past 2 years.
that Tucker is merely anti-Israel when
his newsletter
in his newsletter today he claimed that Zoran Mani is not anti-Semitic.
This was his this is his newsletter today this
>> Asmin Gold's going to get at this too, isn't he? Although
Asmin Gold's been on the anti-Hassan train, a lot of the anti-Hassan
talking points,
I feel like there's some some weird like cognitive crossover
there where people will start applying like, oh, leftist socialist,
he hates Jews, right? So, I don't know. We'll see if Asmin go
can be can overcome the golem programming here and and figure
out what's what. >> I mean, I'm I'm happy to read the text.
It's it's pretty it's it's it's a little extraordinary because
again it is >> is there something that Zoron has done that
is explicitly anti-Semitic
>> and I I asked this as a genuine question because I haven't
seen anything that he said or done. Okay, hold on. Zoron Mandani
globalize
globalize the antifada.
What what where was this said? Where was it? Can I see it? I
want to ask you about an issue that has divided uh some New Yorkers
in recent weeks. You were recently asked about the term globalize
the inifat if it makes you uncomfortable. In that moment, you
did not condemn the phrase. Now, just so folks understand, it's
a phrase that many people hear as a call to violence
>> So, did he say the phrase or did somebody say like condemn
this phrase and he said no thank you.
Is it? There's no way it's truly that he has literally never
said the phrase.
There's no way that all of these people are sowing the out over
him going, "No, I'm good."
How do these people have that position and then love Jordan Peterson?
They forget what Jordan Peterson originally got famous for.
How did Ben Shapiro employ Jordan Peterson if he's going to call
Zora Mandani anti-Semitic over that? >> Jews. There's >> that's
crazy. >> It's very difficult for me to believe that Tucker
is merely anti-Israel when for example today in his newsletter
I mean I can directly quote it if you'd like. In his newsletter
today he claimed that Zoran Mamani is not anti-Semitic.
This was his this is his newsletter today this morning. I mean
I
uh primary reason was compelled speech is bad watching you back.
Compelled speech cannot be allowed under any circumstances was
Jordan Peterson's position. He said, "Even if I thought this
was a good thing to say, the idea of you compelling it is wrong."
Obviously, on its face, the booze. Yeah. Candace says Candace
says if she gets the ticket subs for Megan Kelly, she can prove
a bunch of those people are Daily Wire employees. I think that
would be very funny. >> I'm happy to read the text. It's
it's it's pretty it's it's it's a little extraordinary because
again, it is it is kind of shocking stuff.
So yesterday, Ben Shapi >> Oh, I didn't even realize I
clicked on the wrong video. One that has been genuinely anti-Semitic.
He said he wouldn't v Yeah. Where is it?
>> It is kind of shocking stuff. So, here is what Tucker
Carlson wrote in his newsletter today or what his newsletter
says under his name. He said, >> "You watch the debate
between Destiny and Hijab?" No, I just have no interest. It's
like a religion debate and Destiny's face and/or voice make me
want to vomit usually. So yeah, I'm good.
I I'm sure I'm sure lots of people will cover it wavy if you
want to check it >> Is the incoming mayor a fan of Israel?
Does he want America to fight its wars? Not particularly, but
a hater that's a different conversation. We've never seen >> The
job calls him a puny perverse several times. That sounds funny.
I feel like if I want to watch a debate though, I have to actually
want to follow the points and see who wins the debate. Like understand
who I think wins the debate. And I just don't I'm not really
I don't want to engage with the content that way. So I'm probably
not going to I might do it in a Patreon call or something another
time. Maybe. But yeah, I just I feel like right now for me personally,
it's just not something that's interesting >> thing to
suggest he falls into that ugly camp. If we're talking about
fighting the left, defending Zarani,
who literally said that Hamas, he has no opinion on whether Hamas
should disarm, who posed, >> he shouldn't
he shouldn't have an opinion.
He's the mayor of one city.
He shouldn't be giving his takes on international politics, period.
Oh,
isn't this literally way different than yesterday?
Yesterday I grabbed this clip from from Asmold yesterday. I could
have sworn yesterday he was saying, "Oh yeah, no, it would have
been really good if Zoro Donnie came out against Israel." He
agreed with Sneo. That >> escalated, didn't it? That would
be a good push their narrative that Muslims hate America that
they're trying to destroy for >> here. Hold on.
is that you have a lot of speech, but he didn't shout out white
people.
>> Didn't shout out white people >> and there was
nothing really patriotic. Good for his supporters. But I would
like him to say like, "Hey, I'm going to I'm here to put America
first." And I wanted to hear him mention something about Israel
in his victory speech. I understand why he's not. He's already
that's his number one >> criticism is that he's a you know
he's a >> Shia Islamist blah blah blah terrorist. >> Yeah.
Sure. >> But I think that that would destroy a lot of the
narratives people have that third worlders and immigrants and
stuff like that they shouldn't take office and they shouldn't
even be in this country. >> I think I think it'd be really
good. You know it would destroy the narrative that Muslim people
are in the pocket of Israel.
What the are you talking
that's like conflating America first with being anti-ionist
it's it's just so weird the the like I'm seeing people can't
update their thoughts on things fast enough to like keep up right
there's like this weird crossover happening he was like oh yeah
it would be really good if Zoron made a statement on Israel cuz
that would let people know that he's America first and it's like
bro do you think do you think anybody thought that Zoram Mandani
was on Israel's side.
Have you not seen any of the campaigning they've done? There's
not a single person in the world who was like, "Oh, I think Zoram
Well, actually, now that you say it, now that I say it, I did
see him in Akipia.
I did see him with some leaders and I've seen those pictures
get posted by people conspiratorally posting them." So, but besides
those couple people on Twitter, all right, nobody actually seriously
thinks that.
I just think it's very funny that Asmin Gold was like, "When
Sneo's saying it, yeah. Yeah, I think he should have talked about
Israel. And then when Ben says it, why should he have to talk
about Israel? >> Left defending Zarani
who literally said that Hamas, he has no opinion on whether Hamas
should disarm, who pos
shouldn't have an opinion.
He's the mayor of one city.
He shouldn't be giving his takes on international politics, period.
Why is it why is the mayor of New York City giving his takes
on international? >> Now, I will say going back to this,
there's a chance Asmin Gold was just trying to like wait for
the points he agreed with to come up and that he actually disagreed
with Sneo there and just didn't say so. Small chance >> affairs
at all. What are we doing?
What's What's the next one?
who literally said that he has no opinion on whether should disarm
who posed alongside the 1993 World Trade Center unindicted co-conspirator
who would not >> does that mean that he agrees with
the inifat who suggested that >> I thought that he originally
said to globalize the infot
infidat I I forgot how to pronounce it >> dude I love that
this guy's the biggest political streamer on Twitch God the world
is in such a weird place I love it okay sometimes I just you
It's like a Joker moment.
H globalize the infata. Okay, get it out there. >> He did.
I didn't like his initial answer, but he revised it and he was
just explaining what it meant to these people. I don't know if
he was necessarily supporting it directly.
Enchilada. I know.
>> Okay. It's not enchilada because if it was, I would
support it too.
Whenever there is an a New York police department booed under
I know for a fact it's not inelada to suggest that that's not
anti-semitic in any way. No way. >> Okay. But or when he
when he or >> I don't think it is. >> Give you a
defense of Tucker here and I don't need to defend Tucker. I'm
not
>> I just say I think in general because I know him and
I listen to him and I I understand generally where he's coming
from. He he would say his problems are with Israel. And he would
say that that that shot that Mamani laid against the IDF is a
shot against the IDF and Israel and and how he thinks they're
pro-war, not against >> Yeah. If is Yeah. He doesn't want
to have the New York police. >> He does it every time he's
got his little pun there. Yeah. He looks away. He like lets his
jokes land in like the most obvious way. It's really funny. It
is.
Uh it's the same way like other people can do. It's the same
way you use like a soundboard. He just uses as a visual cue.
It's very funny. >> Police department working with the
IDF. How is that anti-semitic?
>> This is the same type of logic that if you do a
>> Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa. Sick monkey chamber. Thank you
for the nine months. Appreciate it, dude. >> You enforce
crime in minority areas, it means that you're racist.
This is the same type of logic
just inverted. And I think and I think >> all I can say
is when Carlson finds himself in complete alignment with Zoran
Mandani, it is very difficult.
>> Yeah, I lost it there too. Complete alignment. They
only align on one thing, Ben. They only align on one thing. You're
the only person because you are a single issue voter. Because
you are a single issue commentator, you see them as being in
complete alignment. But you're just telling on yourself you're
really not saying anything else. Okay, buddy. for me to believe
that he does not agree with Zorani is in a place right now of
the same place that Charlie was getting to toward the end of
his life. The ch the same place that some people had tried to
drive me, which is you're under withering non-stop accusations
of being something you know you're not. >> Denounce Tucker
Carlson now or be labeled an anti-semite >> from from some
people who >> there are 50 ways that you can criticize
Zoron policies. Why are you choosing the one that's the most
dubious and the greatest?
Why are you doing that?
Him being anti-semitic
is like a this is a a character judgment that can't really be
quantified for sure.
Why are you even talking about this?
And also like by the way tons of there all all rhetorical questions
by the way. Asmin Gold knows exactly why. It's just a rhetorical
question. Don't think he's
Like I I know it's not a consensus. Obviously, there's not a
consensus with this, but there's a lot of that disagree with
Ben Shapiro, too. It's not like every hates Doran Mandami.
And I I think that really
I'm starting to think, dude, is Asmin just the greatest streamer,
but he was hiding for so long. Is he like copying and working
in Aiden Ross' bit where he mispronounces things to be like the
everyman?
Is that what's happening?
>> I I I think that people like Zoran Mandami will consolidate
and grow in power the more that they are misrepresented and mislabeled
in the same way that Trump and also Nick Fentes >> love
and who you've been protecting at least in my case and Charlie's
case for two years who you've been completely defensive of. And
and Charlie and I both felt and I cuz we talked about this on
my show like what's happening here? Why are we they dropping
charges of anti-semitism against us when we love and we're both
open semmites.
>> One more comment. >> I'm not.
>> I'm certainly not. I'll tell you that. And new footage
wasn't a debate. Ben is so clearly morally and factually right.
Uh yeah, I don't know about that one. And uh a lot of people
really seem to think Ben Shapiro came out ahead with
Uh, I really hate to >> We love We're both >> I really
hate to go and do a thing here. Okay, I don't want to be that
guy,
but why don't we go look at that Twitter account. A lot of people
really thinking this guy's correct.
Fishburgger. Hey,
Mr. Fishberger is
that would be him in an IDF uniform, I
Former IDF staff sergeant.
What does he post about? Finally, something Fentus and I agree
on. Grober shouldn't reproduce. Shouldn't he have kids? Ben Shapiro
has been begging Tucker to debate or just sit down for a discussion.
He won't do it. Trying to instead debate Mark freaking Levin
is laughable, laughably weak and telling. Why would you complain
about this when the same comment can be made with Fentes? What
does Zionist occupied government mean exactly? I still don't
even know what Zionist means. So, I I'm very shocked that this
guy thought that this guy's only posts are about anti-semitism
or Israel. I'm very very very shocked to find out that he thought
Ben Shapiro won. That's crazy.
It turns out when your single issue is Israel and you're on the
Israeli side of that, Ben Shapiro is like God. He can't be wrong
on anything.
Wild. Just wild stuff.
Okay. All right. That was a that was a short Asmin Gold segment.
Unfortunately for you guys Okay. Unfortunately for you guys,
watching you back has made me aware of another Asthold segment.
So, we are actually doing backtoback Asmigold content. Now, I
don't know how long this is, but this is um him coming out and
talking about Ben Shapiro
is this Zionist some Hassan tweet.
Zionist SJW's Ben Shapiro and Jake Tapper share a cry over Tucker
Carlson interviewing Nick Fuentes as well as JD Vance not doing
enough to condemn anti-semitism on the right. And Hassan responds,
"Guy who spent his entire career making white supremacist arguments
all of a sudden opposes it when are at the precipice of losing
white status by the Republicans."
Uhoh. This I can tell the reaction already. This is going to
be like when the worst person you know just made a great point,
right? You know the guy's face. The worst person you know just
made a point you agree with. [__] I I feel like Asmin
Gold's one to one on that one. Although,
no. No. Asmin Gold. Asmin Gold can't be enlightened enough to
be one to one on this, can he? I don't think he can.
I don't think so. We'll see. Oh, we don't have sound. >> They
Zoron didn't disavow him. He didn't He didn't disavow him. He
just said that uh he said that what he said about uh 9/11 was
bad, which it was. >> Oh, Asmigold laying out the truth
there as well. Han stacking W's in the Asmigold stream. Get the
out of here.
Get the out of here. He just said he just admitted that Zoro
Mandani didn't actually disavow him. He just said that 911 combo
was really bad. I disagree with that. >> Was bad. Obviously,
it sounded bad. So, >> Yes. Because Fentes, if he doesn't
hate hate Die Booby, is just Donald Trump in 2015, 2016.
The same guy that Ben after Donald Trump won, Ben just decided
to start filating this guy. Okay. Ben was opposed to him originally
in the same way he's opposed to Fuentes now.
Yes. But is just the energy of the Trump campaign manifest. All
right.
>> I think that Kevin really screwed things up last week
when he decided to inject himself into this controversy with
his viferous defense that that contains some >> Kevin Roberts
from the Heritage >> Language. I think he's doing the right
thing by pointing out the obvious, which is that if somebody
glosses
on the air, that person probably should not. >> Is he still
fighting to make people not bring Nick Fuentes on TV? How long
is this going to go on? Does he know that this is like it's just
going to get
Like this is you're you're not going to win this argument. Here's
the thing, Chatty Nickel. That doesn't work. People think that
that like the general populace is that stupid. The general populace
is stupid, but they're stupid in a fairly consistent way.
They can be turned away from Trump by somebody like Fuentes.
They can.
People just don't realize it. And if Fentes decided to take a
bag to start railing against Islam, he stopped talking about
Israel, he would have somebody who was charismatic who would
rise up and go, "Hey, Nick Fuentes, why won't you talk about
Israel?"
Right? In the same way, it would be the same, literally the same
rhetoric. Nick would have laid the groundwork for the exact thing
that would be used to criticize him.
They're going to bring him on anyway. And here's the reason why,
Ben. It's because Nick brings in
He brings in views from people that love him and he brings in
views from people that hate him.
That's why he gets invited. You can get mad and cry and [__]
about it all you want, but at the end of the day, these places
don't care about America. They don't care about Israel either.
And guess what? They're going to upload whatever they think is
going to make them the most money. And if that means interviewing
what you think a you're a white supremacist is, they're going
to do it. That's just it. >> Not be associated with a conservative
think tank and that everyone should have a duty to say that that
is a bad thing to do. So I'm grateful to Kevin for doing that.
I think it's a very good thing that he did that. that the real
issue here is I think that Tucker Carlson's morphing from, I
would say, a very edgy right-wing political figure on Fox News,
but certainly within the mainstream, into a conspiracist, a person
who ideologically laers anti-semitism, who ideologically laers
all sorts of anti-Americanism on his show and then errors it
for for the public to hear with interviews like the ones he did
with Nick Fuentes, which was essentially a massage of Nick Fuentes.
You know, I think that took a lot of people by surprise, probably
including >> Sneo's back in Miami. I see Sneo in his Miami
apartment right now streaming.
>> People were really positive about it. If you look at
the video, it had a tremendous positive reaction. And I mean
like the likes and dislikes. I mean, it is what it is,
>> dude. And by the way, just to point it out, like Ben
is struggling right now.
I don't know if it's Broken Containment on the main on just the
Fuentes videos, but all of all of Ben's like primary videos essentially
are people talking about America first. Let's see this one. 713,000
news. I'm >> Is this one Is this one America First?
New Yorkers. Oh, it also might be getting deleted, right?
For quite a while, all of this stuff was just like America first,
Ben's going to lose. Ben's going to lose. America first, etc.
Right.
It's full week. >> New York voters walk off a cliff.
Today's comment section is a thousand times more comforting than
yesterday's.
There's like a bunch of his comment sections that were just getting
bombed
The vid you watched yesterday, Candace invited him to her show
since it's the bigger one now. Candace is massive. Candace is
actually the the You think Fuentes is hurting?
Fend Candace is hurting like the most cognitively disabled audience
I've ever seen. Like that they just keep buying everything she
sells them. She doesn't do anything to prove anything. She's
constantly called a liar and has no proof to back up anything
she says and nobody cares.
But her audience is massive. It's like so big. It's crazy. Anyway,
go back to this Asmin clip here. >> A lot of people were
really happy about it. Now, obviously maybe his friends and he
wasn't happy about it. That's fine. But this is kind of true
actually. Yeah. I mean I I >> I'm not positive about it.
I I obviously not everybody is, but I'm saying like if you you're
you're making a collective analysis, aren't you?
>> Free Beacon obtained and posted video of yesterday's
Heritage Foundation staff meeting uh where Roberts apologized
for how he's handled Tucker's conversation with Nick F. Here's
part of what Roberts had to say. >> What did he say? Is
this the bald guy? >> I didn't. Dude, I by the way, I know
it seems like I'm just like shadowing Asminold and stuff. Asminold
happens to be as like interested in this arc as I am. So, he's
the person I'm grabbing clips of. If other people were commenting
as much, like I've got some Young Turk stuff. They've been commenting,
but other than TYT and Asmin Gold, there's been quite a few people
that have done like one video and moved on when there's so much
content here. This is like I don't even know what other people
are doing for content. If you're not following this stuff, this
is like the most exciting thing happening on the internet right
now. I don't Yeah. I actually don't. Yeah, >> know much
about this Fente guy. I still
Which underscores the mistake. I can tell you. >> Also,
one second. I'm going to be listening, but I need to use that
real quick. I'll be right back. >> Any excuses
that those were my intentions to fix all of that and obviously
I didn't. I made them worse.
>> We reached out to the Heritage Foundation for comment
about the video. We were referred to Kevin Roberts social media
post from yesterday. What's your reaction? And let me just just
note that Nick Fuentes has been fairly notorious for years now,
including when he dined with President Trump at Mara Lago.
>> I mean, I think that's true, but I think that really
in order to experience the the full wonders of the Nick Fentes
catalog, you really do have to spend some time going through
the receipts. I did that earlier this week on my show. And the
the truth is that most people don't watch politics all that granularly.
Even people who are in politics don't spend a lot of time on
sort of the fringe edge lord right the way that that that Fuentes
is. And and so the the sort of mainstreaming the popularization
and normalization of Fuentes by Carlson is significantly more
important than just Fuentes's existence. >> he just wants
to be a gatekeeper.
It's never going to work. [snorts] It didn't work with leftwing
people trying to keep people like Zoran out. It's not going to
work with Fentes either. It's just you can't gatekeep people
out. You have to beat them in the marketplace of ideas. And if
you don't do that, you're going to fail. That's literally it.
Um, there's no other way besides that that you can overcome an
idea. That's it. You you you can't just tell everybody you're
not allowed to. He can't sit at your table. I I mean, I It's
so simple. Yeah. It's just not going to work. Do you like Nick's
views or no? Some I agree with, some I don't. I mean, it's the
same with anything. I mean, like, I I think he's funny. Uh, for
sure he's definitely funny, but like uh it's not like I agree
with everything he says, but I agree
I'm back. I had to go get water as well. Holy, how does how does
Asmin Gold not somehow does it not strike him that he was arguing
Hassan needs to be banned from Twitch?
How does it not strike him at all that he was the guy trying
to gatekeep Hassan?
It like he doesn't see it. He doesn't see it at all. He And I
think this is just obvious, right? It's just evident on its face
that he thinks Hassan is worse than Nick Fuentes, possibly by
a lot.
No,
that he would be trying to talk about how Hassan should be banned.
He'd be highlighting him, criticizing him all the time. I haven't
seen one tiny bit as much criticism for
It's crazy.
Um,
and then what was I going to say? I do think that there's this
weird narrative that Nick is entirely being popularized by Tucker
Carlson. Tucker Carlson is moving out of the way, right? Tucker
Carlson isn't raising Nick up. He's getting the [__]
out of the way as Nick blows past him in the race
is way >> A lot of it. Not really. Maybe a lot of it. I'd
say like maybe some of it. Depends. I'd have to really think
about
>> Does Fentes support terrorism? Uh, yeah. I'm pretty
sure Fentes would have like actually openly just supported the
people who were resisting Israel.
And I think he has like openly on his show. What the [__]
are you talking about? Yeah.
Hey, what's what's Fentes's number one issue? Who does he think
are the worst people on the planet? Does he support the people
opposing those people? Yeah, obviously.
>> It was a seinal >> like I'm not really a big racist,
you know? I'm not I don't really dislike races of people. And
I'm not really,
but I I agree with a lot of what his opinions are on Israel as
a collective, but not really in terms of people as a collective,
if that makes sense.
The uh the only difference between Fuentes and Hassan is that
Fuentes probably wants to kill the people that were doing terrorism
on Israel after they do terrorism on Israel. Okay. After Israel's
defeated, he would probably want to go after those people, too.
Retake the Holy Land kind of deal, you know?
But that's a that's a later step. He's not talking about that
one yet. He's not advertising that one yet. All right.
He's not. I think when it comes to the rights decision as to
whether Tucker himself is is a source of truth or whether he
is a a destructive force inside conservatism. >> So one
of the things you've noted is is that well I think that the it's
again it's the framing right it's that he's the one that's the
destructive force. Well, what happens whenever the majority is
the opposite of you and you're the destructive force, right?
And I think this is the real question that people like Ben Shapiro
need to ask themselves is that whenever you're telling people
and trying to,
you know, like orange guy bad. Yeah. I mean, it's the same thing
like it's like, oh, you can't platform Trump, you can't talk
about Trump, like you can't bring him on, like he's so bad. That
will just never work, man. So, basically, Hassan views on Israel.
Um, I think [laughter] his song is a bit
Hold on. Hold on. >> Is that whenever you're telling people
and trying to
>> you know, like orange guy bad? Yeah. I mean, it's the
same thing like it's like, "Oh, you can't platform Trump. You
can't talk about Trump. Like, you can't bring him on. Like, he's
so bad." That will just never work, man. So, basically, Hassan
views on Israel. Um, I think Hassan is a bit more extreme about
Israel than I am. I think that like he probably agrees like I
agree with Hassan about like I'd say 70 to 80% about what he
says about Israel, but I don't like how he I think that Hassan
at least it seems to me actively denies I think a lot of the
the victimhood that Israelis have experienced uh against like
by
or by I don't think that's true. I actually don't think that
I think he doesn't want to spend time talking about it, but I
don't think I've ever heard him go, "No, no, no. Nobody died
on October 7." No, no, no, no. The worst part again is the denial
of like assaults or the, you know, performative,
what would you say? Like the the the stuper he enters when he
talks about that stuff where he pretends he doesn't really understand
it. >> Other types of terrorist attacks or bombings. And
so I I think that you can recognize that, you know, Israelis
have experienced trauma as well in this war while also acknowledging
that the country that they are part of is the, you know, maybe
antagonist to that. So like I think that's probably the main
difference that he and I have, but I think that's mainly uh it
it's that's like kind of a vibe thing. I don't really care a
lot about that.
He astrotars for I I think that he's not critical enough of them.
I I do. But o overall, I mean, I think that's it's kind of a
dead issue at this point, right? Because it seems like that's
kind of winding down, at least hopefully. >> it isn't.
>> You know what, Asmin Gold? I think you're right. I think
we've achieved permanent peace in the Holy Land.
>> Yep. I think that's that seems likely to me. Permanent
peace in the Holy Land,
so much your problem isn't so much that Tucker Carlson had point
this on his show, but that he didn't push back at all on the
anti-Semitic pro- Joseph Stalin rhetoric, etc. I just wonder
uh last week at a turning point event, Vice President JD Vance
was asked, >> I think this is a, as I said before, I talked
about this interview that Tucker Carlson did, too. And I think
that actually Ben Shapiro has very like I think valid criticism
towards Tucker Carlson that when Tucker Carlson interviews people
that are extremely controversial that he doesn't press them on
their controversial beliefs enough. And I think that it does
a disservice to his viewers and it would be better for the viewers
if they were able to actually, you know, hear the answers to
some of the questions like, you know, why are you would you say
that you're anti-Semitic? Like, you know, that that kind of stuff.
And I think that like no Joseph Stalin. Well, I'm Wait, did I
say pro Joseph Stalin? I I don't think that's what he said. The
Ben Shapiro >> I mean that that literally unfortunately
that is a bit of a it's a bit of a what would you call it? Like
a a mindmelter. Okay, that'll that'll do something to your brain.
But but that is accurate. Okay.
Stalin supporter. >> You Netanyahu with tough questions
>> kind of wrinkles the brain. I think that's a great counterpoint.
That's a great that that that is an incredible counterpoint.
I never thought of that.
But I think that you can use that actually to make Ben's point
is that if you he did. Okay. Well, maybe he did. Yeah. I I don't
know. I didn't watch it, so I I I assume that he didn't, but
maybe. Yeah. Uh either way, um you know, if he didn't ask him
tough questions, then >> uh pensive goat, I think there's
a clip on this from last night where people ask him about him
supporting Stalin or something like how do you support monsters
like Stalin and he's like, "No, just tell me that which which
like historical leader I should support that didn't murder people."
Kind of a total evasion, right? And uh it would assume that,
you know, he's projecting onto Tucker Carlson. Well, if you're
not asking him tough questions, maybe you agree with him like
I do.
>> So yeah.
by student about an anti-Semitic falsehood. This crazy notion
that Judaism openly supports the persecution of Christians. It's
not true. Um but JD Vance was asked about it. Instead of pushing
back or correcting the questioner, he said this. >> Well,
the problem is like I mean I >> is is Jake Tapper trying
to exacerbate Ben's JN.
>> Hey, I don't know if you saw this, but there's actually
more anti-semitism than you even realized, Ben. I'm just going
to show you this clip. heard things like this is like I've never
read the Torah or the Talmud, but I've heard that basically
people consider
people as a separate class. Like that's the whole goyam thing.
And I think that really I don't know how and like I I and a lot
of religions have a variation of this, right? It's not true.
Well, that Well, I'm just saying like this is a commonly held
belief that people have. It's Muslims too. Yeah. Yeah, I know
that. It's a commonly held belief. So I I think that really addressing
that is important to just say you see the the Pope was talking
about the treatment of illegal immigrants.
Bro,
I get that illegal immigrant treatment is like a problem in the
US, but hey, your citizens are also being treated like illegal
immigrants. So I think you guys got a lot of things to work on.
I don't know if the Pope is is getting that priority list correct
right now. Okay? They're [laughter] they're treating the illegal
immigrants like animals and the citizens like illegal immigrants.
Okay? It's not good. Something's got to change. there are some
significant theological disagreements between Christians and
Jews. My attitude is let's have those conversations. Let's have
those disagreements when we have them. But if there are shared
areas of interest, we ought to be willing to do that, too. >> And
and let me guess, that's a problem.
That's a perfect answer. That's what I want to hear.
That I agree with him. >> What did you think of that? >> You
know, obviously in a vacuum, I think that answer is fine. You
can only This is dude I've it sucks so badly, but I've I've realized
slowly over time that
you
people like lefties I feel like used to say you can only argue
with somebody who tells the truth, right? You can't have an argument
with somebody who's not willing to engage in like what the truth
is. And I thought that was like a cope for a long time. And I've
I've certainly come to realize like obviously it's true, but
it's like the idea that so many people are lying is probably
what the cope is. Like some people, most people do believe the
things they say to some extent, right? But then I see somebody
like Fentes who I am like positive is just telling a story, who
is not really engaging in reality, who when he has counterpoints
to like the things he says, he doesn't really care cuz he knows
his story can overcome it. And then I'm like, "Oh yeah, that
that the idea that you just go and open debate these people,
it doesn't I don't know that that can work, man. I don't I don't
know if it can work." >> Fine. I think it's a respons
Sorry. I don't know if enough people can actually tell the difference
between like what's
right? They they can't look at somebody arguing with Fuentes.
Dean his story. He's scared of Dean. He lost to Dean. He lost
to Dean cuz Dean's soy. Dean's like a loser. I'm sorry. Dean
is like clearly using chat GPT and just like yelling stuff at
him. Yeah, Dean was totally in that debate.
I'm telling you, that's the other thing is you've got again,
people keep thinking that a lefty can stop the rise of Fuentes.
That can't happen. You have to have somebody who's on that
It's like basically
every Republican is on this balancing beam, right? They're on
a balancing beam and Fuentes is the person who is dead set in
the center of that balance beam. He's got his feet set there.
Somebody has to push him off the center of that balance beam.
That balance beam is like the MAGA ideals, the MAGA principles,
such as they are, right? It's all the principles they have. It's
all the things they've been uh campaigning on. And Fuentes is
standing square in the middle of it. And somebody has to push
him out. But unfortunately, to actually even engage in pushing
him out, you have to be able to stand on the balance beam. Ben
Shapiro can't stand on the balance beam. Requires denouncing
Israel, denouncing Netanyahu,
right? Matt Walsh can't stand on the balance beam. Similar reasons
on Israel, not all the same. But then the issue is Matt Walsh
then once he's on the balance beam then you're in then you're
in a like an actual war with somebody. You have to be more car
more charismatic, funnier, a better arguer than them. I don't
think Matt Walsh is capable. Right. So Matt Walsh might be able
to stand on the balance beam and engage in this pushing war to
get Fuentes out of this driver's seat in the GOP, but I don't
know that he's capable of like actually winning that war once
he's
No, winning from the left doesn't matter. The left's been winning
for a long time, bro. They've been they've been winning factually
for a long time. Facts don't matter. Okay, it turns out Ben Shapiro
got it exactly wrong in 2008 or whenever he started debating.
Facts do care about your feelings. In fact, the feeling your
feelings don't care about facts
and Fuentes knows that and Fuentes is just going to tap into
people's emotion. Not going to worry about he's not going to
worry about something pesky like the >> Question which
was asked as you say in a tremendously anti-semitic way. the
the idea that that Jews are persecutors of Christians uh is is
an absurd contention. Obviously, I would have preferred more
from the Ben needs to stop using the word uh every by the way,
regardless of how you could literally be arguing against Fentes,
just stop pointing out that he's anti-Semitic.
I'm telling you, it is the the unfortunate reality is in right-wing
circles that is now working against you. That is actually hurting
you. When you make that allegation, it doesn't matter if this
guy, if you could play the clip of him literally do throwing
up a Roman and saying, "I love," okay? Doesn't matter if you
can do that. It still hurts you.
Stop making the allegation. Stop using it as a label. It's just
like racist when all the people like came, you know, when there's
the the backlash against cancel culture. It's just like that.
Stop using it. It actually hurts you in these shows. But you
have Jake Tapper here who's like a center-left liberal, and he's
going to clap for you doing that. Absolutely he will >> the
vice president but I think the broader problem here is again
that you have an enormous number of young >> I just I don't
know enough about
the actual religion to I I don't know >> young people who
are engaging with true white supremacist
content and are taken in by it and there do need to be more voices
pushing back on that >> spir we thank you for your voice
thank you so much >> so the Heritage Foundation apologized
and then they unapologized then they reap apologized
is this is this correct I just want to make sure I'm understanding
Yeah. Let me go back. I'll see if I can find it. There it is.
>> Oh, he's going to go through all of this
>> Bad either.
That's just me. It's just racism. Um, yeah, it's racism. And
to the extent that you're criticizing a religion, are we going
to say that criticizing Judaism is is now off the table? That's
total bull. It's the same that's I say the same thing about Islam
and Christianity. I grew up criticizing Christianity. Thank you,
>> uh, Chatty Nickel4, thank you for the gifted sub. Appreciate
it, buddy. >> Um, I I've heard a lot of bad things about
Islam. That's why I said I wanted to read the Quran. Same with
the the Talmud, right? I mean, I want to read it. Like, what
what does it actually say, right? Because there's so much misinformation
that goes around. But the fact is that all of it is the same.
It's fundamentally the same. No one is saying that. They are.
They're saying it in a way. And I think that it comes off that
And whether you agree with that or not, that's your opinion.
But I'm telling you how I how I'm seeing it and my perspective
is that whenever you're creating one category that is seemingly
being elevated above other categories, it seems like you're picking
favorites to me.
You want to read the Quran? Yeah,
No, you don't.
It's a book that two billion people in the world follow.
I want to know why. Asmin Gold wants to read the Quran in the
way that like if they developed the matrix technology where they
could press the button and download the Quran into his brain,
he would accept it. But that is like the only circumstance under
which he would read the Quran. Like that is that's all it is
right there, right? Doesn't actually care like that. Sorry, doesn't
care enough to read it. He's just like, "Yeah, I would, you know,
I'd love to read the Quran. Yeah, I
like uh it's like a fat guy saying, "Yeah, I'd love to go to
the gym. I'd love to, you know, January 1st, that's when we're
going to the gym, guys. Like, no, you're not. Just uh stop at
the cope, bro. >> Is that stupid? Wrestle with hard conversations,
not avoid them.
Last night's election results demonstrate
>> The need of this moment is clear. We must articulate
a bold, positive vision that convinces Americans that conservative
policies will revitalize the American dream.
The left isn't slowing down. If we want to win, truly win, we
must grow stronger in every way. Here is what we are focused
on moving forward.
Standing for strong families because no society survives without
them.
>> Advocating for the dignity of work and free enterprise
because it's how people build meaning and sustain freedom.
>> Defending national sovereignty
because a country that doesn't protect itself isn't a country.
>> Yeah. and restoring citizenship as a sacred trust rooted
in virtue, liberty, and faith. It's not just policy, it's purpose.
So to each >> Well, if you're rooting it in faith, which
faith
>> shouldn't you elaborate on that? >> Of you working
the long hours, holding the line, doing the >> I just find
Don't you find that to be
>> Why is he re-watching? >> Grateful guy this Jesus,
bro. like that. Like this is really Wow. I don't even know what
to say. Extremely. It's such a limp response. Yeah. It doesn't
even mean anything. Like you're not even saying anything. It's
so boring. [snorts] Like Yeah. It sounds like he's talking to
people's grandparents and kids. Yeah. It's just my dick has never
been softer. I mean, that's a fact, isn't it? Oh, what?
What?
What? What? Pardon me. Sorry. I got the the sneak bit here. I
got this. Oh, I just realized I got to fix it on the soundboard
though. Hold on. Uh,
we do this one.
This one.
We should We can build up the moments with it. Okay. Although
the bass is so deep that sometimes my headphones peak. It's kind
of weird. Yeah. >> H Oh my god. >> I figure how to
work it in. Okay. >> Boring. Yeah. I I don't even know
what to say about this. And And there's more of these. Why is
socialism spreading? This is something else. Uh, I might look
at this. I'll probably follow these guys. I think that they'll
have good things for me to react to and complain about. This
will be great. So, yeah. Top comment. Oh, yeah. Nick was obviously
not a fan of it. I wonder why. [snorts] Playing a game today.
Not today, but probably in a couple of days, if not tomorrow.
That's my plan. Uh, what will we be playing? I don't know. I'll
probably put it in a title if we're going to be playing something.
But yes, uh, that is the uh that is the plan. [snorts] Dispatch.
A lot of people want Dispatch. They do. >> I'm like slowly
over time learning a lot from Asmin Gold on streaming. Okay,
>> a lot of you guys want Dispatch and I might try it out.
I might try it out because again, a lot of people want it and
maybe it'll be really fun. >> That's it for Asmin Asmin
content. All right, we finished our GOP Civil War stuff. I think
Hilo sent me a clip. Let me see if I can find this clip for you
guys real quick. Give me a second. Give me a second.
Gotta go find this clip. It's right here.
Oh, no, it's not. What? Hold on.
Go to Discord and grab it. Give me a
Apparently, Mr. Girl was live today. So, he sent me a clip of
Mr. Girl. He said, "This is this is really funny. You should
look at this." Is it Kilo endorsed clip? Kilotonics. Okay. Not
my >> What is with these women?
True, true. Oh my god.
Oh my god. >> Who posts Tik Toks
and they're like, "Oh, look at me. I'm Look at me in my my uh
gymnastics outfit. Um, you know, college girl, you know, college
girls. Look at my outfit. It's media day." And then they don't
turn around. I'm like, "Wow,
that's the, you know, the problem we all have." Yes. I You know
what? You know what? I get literally just make a separate feed
for all the women who don't turn around during their Tik Toks
cuz I don't care. I'm [laughter] >> Dude, anybody listen,
if I can't get a 360 view, I just want an entirely different
TikTok that forces a 360 view. >> I don't I think I'm literally
not attracted to the front half of a woman.
>> Wait, hold on. No, I think bisect means uh it has to
be symmetrical, right? I think he's technically incorrect here.
>> See, and that's how it happens. Another academic paper
right there.
>> You can screenshot
any woman who refuses to turn around. Upload that screenshot
to Grock
>> and just type turn around. You can make her do whatever
you want. Grock,
>> bro. What? What? >> We'll make her do whatever
you want. Although there is you there's like seems like the the
not safe for work filter is a little more strict when you're
importing a picture. But yeah, there are these two college girls.
>> Dude, what the is happening?
>> That were like kept facing me. So I screenshotted them,
uploaded it, and I just I said, "But [laughter] >> what?"
I screenshotted it and I said
but butt twerk butt dance, you know.
>> And they did. Sometimes Groc to see I like a sad butt.
Sometimes Grock will make them um do like fake faces where like
it's trained on fake fake women faking it. So then when it tries
to draw a woman actually like, "Oh, I'm going to twerk for you."
She's like, which is not I'm I'm not interested.
Turn around.
I'd like to see your face. Don't smile
unless you really mean it.